voilà monsieur bonsoir aussi les titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 25 décembre
la première image quasi officiel de
l'idylle présidentielle nicolas sarkozy
main dans la main avec la chanteuse
carla bruni pour une nouvelle escapade
amoureuse
cette fois à louxor en egypte les voeux
de noël du pape benoît 16 un appel pour
la paix dans le monde en particulier en
irak au liban et en terre sainte dans
son message urbi est en vie les sages de
noël aussi pour la reine d'angleterre
qui cette année innove sur internet
c'est toute l'histoire de la famille
britannique les disques livres 2 sur un
canal évidemment royal spécialement
créés sur le site youtube et sur
internet toujours on retrouve dès
aujourd'hui à la vente les cadeaux dont
certains n'ont pas plu ou que certains
possédez déjà
dès 10 heures ce matin des centaines de
milliers d'articles et et aux enchères
loin très loin des fracas et des
tumultes du monde la ville de rishikesh
au pied de l'himalaya capitale mondiale
de la méditation et du yoga reçoit
chaque année des milliers de pèlerins
dans cet ashram et puis pour débuter ce
journal une flamme pour ingrid
betancourt une bougie a placé
aujourd'hui jour de noël sur le rebord
de sa fenêtre en signe de solidarité
cette bougie la voici
ce 25 décembre est aussi l'anniversaire
d'ingrid betancourt qui a 46 ans
aujourd'hui et qui est détenu depuis
presque six ans à issy les moulineaux
près de paris sur la place de l'hôtel de
ville
près de 200 bougies ont été allumées
dans le cadre de l'opération la flamme
de l'espoir pour ingrid et les autres
otages en colombie les vacances
présidentielles arrivée très attendue
cet après-midi à louxor du nouveau
couple eut le plus traqué par les
paparazzi
le président français nicolas sarkozy et
la chanteuse carla bruni se sont pour la
première fois affiché main dans la main
à l'entrée du palace hall winter en
hôtel victoria situé en bordure du nil
ils ont ensuite effectué une promenade
le long du fleuve suivie par une armada
de photographes et de badauds sur place
le reportage de franck gêne aux eaux et
ahmed salah
main dans la main sur la corniche de
louxor ils profitent de la nuit qui
tombe sur la lune
nicolas sarkozy et l'ex mannequin carla
bruni ne cachent plus leur idylle
escorté par de nombreux policiers en
civil quelques clichés offert aux
photographes puis les paparazzi sont
vite prié d'aller voir ailleurs
épilogue d'un après midi agitée dans la
cité égyptienne quelques heures plus tôt
très peu de photographes à l'arrivée du
convoi présidentiel
et pour cause une rumeur annoncé le
président à l'autre bout de la ville
ceux qui ne sont pas tombés dans le
piège ont eu la photo du jour ils se
tiennent la main explique celui ci
elle est là l'histoire c'est pour ça que
j'étais venu un petit geste en direction
des badauds puis le couple disparaît
sous l'oeil de touristes français
partagés parce que la publicité avec sa
vue imprenable sur le nil
ces jardins exotiques et sa piscine lol
winter palace accueillera les invités du
président durant trois jours en moyenne
500 euros la nuit par chambre
l'entourage présidentiel en aurait
réservé une vingtaine selon certains
responsables locaux la délégation
devrait se rendre aux célèbres temples
de karnak où il pourrait croiser
l'ancien premier ministre tony blair lui
aussi annoncé sur les bords du nil
le temple de louxor ou encore la tombe
de néfertari nicolas sarkozy voulait
tant voyage discret mais il est prévu un
agenda chargé
il devra encore composer avec la
présence des paparazzi à rome le pape
benoît 16 a appelé à la paix pour le
monde dans tous les lieux où résonne le
bruit des armes at il dit dans son
message urbi et orbi il a dénoncé le
terrorisme et les violences qui frappent
les plus vulnérables enfants femmes et
personnes âgées reportage au vatican
philippe visseyrias et karine guillaume
noël au vatican a ses rituels en fin de
matinée lors qu'istres des carabiniers
se met en place au pied de la basilique
saint-pierre puis du haut du balcon
benoît 16 lens en 63 langues sa
traditionnelle bénédiction urbi et orbi
à la ville et au christ sauveur
regardant l'espérance et qu'il vous
fasse le don de la paix profonde du
darfour à la somalie de l'irak au liban
et à l'afghanistan
le pape dénonce les guerres et le
terrorisme en ce jour de paye ma pensée
se tournent surtout vers les lieux où
résonne le bruit des armes un message de
paix de réconciliation qu'attendaient
les milliers de pèlerins place saint
pierre
on est heureux d'être là on se sent de
proximité pour voilà de la dimension
d'église si la dimension universelle
et puis et la joie d'être chrétiens ça
redonne un peu un élan seamobile a
toujours été dans la préoccupation des
chrétiens que la paix se fasse entre les
hommes
c'est le sens de la fête de noël des
fidèles déjà présents la nuit dernière
venue chercher à rome un supplément
d'âme puisque à paris sa a perdu un
petit peu de son âme en ce moment et on
retrouve pas noël c'est un peu fade
pendant la messe de minuit benoît 16 a
dénoncé les conditions dans lesquelles
se trouve la terre en raison at il dit
de l'exploitation égoïste qu'en font les
hommes
si le message de paix délivrée par
benoît 16 et traditionnelles en ce jour
de noël
celui sur la protection de la planète et
plus inattendu il montre à quel point ce
thème est devenu primordial pour le
vatican est partout dans le monde
bethléem en amérique latine les
chrétiens se sont recueillis à
l'occasion de cette nativité du christ
symbole d'espoir et de réconciliation
pour les croyants mallory yahoo nous et
grégory vasseur basilique de la nativité
à bethléem hier à minuit le patriarche
latin de jérusalem a prié pour un proche
orient pacifié devant le leader
palestinien mahmoud abbas et des
milliers de fidèles qui n'ont pas tous
pu entrer
j'avais très envie d'être ici là le soir
de noël en a beaucoup de problèmes par
là la baisse la ville natale du christ
n'avait pas attiré autant de pèlerins et
de touristes depuis 2000 et la seconde
intifada
on rêve de paix de stabilité ici aussi à
bagdad
malgré la peur la minorité chrétienne a
rejoint les églises une messe du matin
remplacer celle de minuit pour des
raisons sécurité autres minorités de
chrétiens en chine
seulement 3% de la population et des
relations gelé avec le vatican met d
église bondée
beaucoup sont venus par curiosité pour
la culture occidentale
les troupes allemandes italiennes et
françaises qui s'est fait en afghanistan
ont elles eu droit à un repas spécial
pour certains c'est le premier noël - de
la famille à notre dame de paris
monseigneur andré vingt-trois a
justement prier pour eux sa messe de
minuit à emule emilie les participants
c'est deux ou trois ans que j'ai pas été
à l'église et ses sept îles est vraiment
spéciale il ya la beauté d'événements et
puis c'est noël noël tout simplement
c'est en maillot de bain pour les
australiens malgré un temps couvert
c'est profondément sous marins pour ses
plongeurs de la mer noire et enfin
treize aérien pour les astronautes de la
station spatiale internationale
un cargo ci arrivera demain avec un bord
de la nourriture et des cadeaux hier
soir dans le petit village de classe
dans les alpes-maritimes une soixantaine
de personnes ont été hospitalisées à
l'issue de la messe de noël victimes
d'intoxication au monoxyde de carbone 20
villageois ont été placées en caisson
hyperbare aucun d'entre eux n'est en
danger mais il faut rappeler que 300
personnes meurent chaque hiver de ce
type d'intoxication arnault compte
voyez l'appareil un petit chauffage au
gaz installées ici il ya 55 ans voilà
comment la messe de noël a tourné à
l'intoxication
hier vers 18 heures pratiquement tout le
village assiste à la célébration à la
sortie de l'office les fidèles partagent
un vin chaud
plusieurs d'entre eux se plaignent alors
de vomissements et de maux de tête 68
personnes sont hospitalisées
une vingtaine placé sous oxygène pendant
six heures nos amis les masques à
oxygène
et ce matin on fait une piqûre pour voir
si ça avait baissé cet après midi toutes
les personnes incommodées ont pu quitter
les hôpitaux de la côte d'azur avec dans
la poche un étrange souvenir du
réveillon cadeaux de noël
je me mets toujours sur le chauffage
mais hier soir
louise harel a dit monde quand charles
de leucan pick up a toi alors je suis
monté j'ai quitté le chauffage et c'est
ce qui m'a sauvé chaque année le
monoxyde de carbone ce gaz invisible et
inodore est à l'origine de 6000
intoxication dont 300 sont mortelles et
puis en guadeloupe quatre jeunes de 15 à
17 ans ont été mis en examen et écroué
après un incendie qui a fait sept morts
dans un magasin selon le parquet cet
incendie aurait été causé par un pétard
allumé pour faire diversion lors de
tentatives de vol de feux d'artifice
dans ce bazar appartenant à des
ressortissants chinois
un des adolescents a péri dans un
incendie en mauritanie alors que des
autorités locales recherche activement
tous les hommes qui ont tiré sur cinq
touristes français hier en en tuant
quatre parmi eux deux mauritaniens en
fuite serait proche du groupe islamiste
salafiste affiliés à al qaïda le seul
français sur ig en septuagénaire blessé
à la jambe a été transféré à dakar elles
devraient être rapatriés en france
mercredi enquête karine comazzi et
frédéric guiraud il est fait partie par
amour de l'afrique
françois teulet est aujourd'hui le seul
rescapé d'une randonnée qui s'est
achevée dans le sang
grièvement blessé à la jambe ce
charentais de 73 ans a été transféré
dans la nuit à l'hôpital des armées de
dakar c'est un médecin qui lui a appris
que ses deux fils son frère et son amie
sont morts l'ambassadeur de france ait
rendu à son chevet quand on l'a reçu ce
matin il était 2h à peu près était
surtout très inquiet de savoir ce qui
était arrivé à ses compagnons ils ne
savaient pas qu'ils étaient morts
on veut annoncé tout à l'heure contre
président concerne homme d'expérience
c'est un homme qui connaît bien
l'afrique fait déjà beaucoup de voyages
de ce type
bon il a accusé le coup évidemment le
drame s'est déroulé ici
le groupe de français avait décidé de
s'offrir ne halte un pique nique sous
les arbres avant de reprendre cette
route vers le mali voisin
pour ce qu'ils ont vu arriver dans cette
voiture 3e manche et armés de fusils
automatiques
les hommes armés ont demandé de l'argent
l'un des touristes venaient de changer
des devises à aleg sous les yeux des
agresseurs ce qui laisse supposer qu'ils
les ont suivis jusqu'à 9 kilomètres de
la ville pour l'argent les traces de son
côté la police mauritanienne mène l
enquête tous azimuts
cinq personnes sont interrogées parmi
elles un chauffeur de taxi qui aurait
pris en charge les tireurs trois hommes
actuellement en fuite vers le sénégal
deux d'entre eux sont soupçonnés
d'appartenir au gspc un groupe proche
d'al qaïda c'est ce qu'annonce ce soir
la justice mauritanienne
petite révolution dans l' équilibre dans
l'économie mondiale de l'automobile
c'est désormais le constructeur japonais
toyota qui devient le premier producteur
mondial devant le géant américain
general motors qui depuis presque 80 ans
régné sans partage mais toyota depuis
quelques années a investi dans des
véhicules économes en carburant ou
hybrides qu'ils ont rencontrés y compris
aux états unis un succès spectaculaire
valérie le rouge
voici les premières toyota des métiers à
tisser mécanique l'unique activité de la
marque japonaise dans les années 20
pendant ce temps les américains
produisent déjà en série les premières
voitures une avance une suprématie que
ford et general motors garderont durant
76 ans mais toyota apprend vite et
s'exporte rapidement la marque
s'installe en france dans les années 70
une nouvelle voiture japonaise vient
d'arriver sur le marché européen il
s'agit de la toyota starlette un
véhicule original
les modèles sont basiques robuste mais
pas encore pris au sérieux
oh bien sûr on ne retrouve pas encore le
confort et les qualités routières d'une
r5 ou d'une 104 - aux portables que les
françaises mais aussi moins chers les
ventes décollent toyota occupe déjà la
troisième place mondiale
trente ans plus tard c'est le premier
producteur au monde 9 million et demi de
voitures soit 200 milles de plus que
general motors
loin des marques françaises qui tourne
autour de 3 millions la force de toyota
l'innovation c'est le japonais qui a
commercialisé la première voiture
hybride la prius moteur à essence et
électricité et ses modèles sont fiables
le moteur ne tombe en panne ya très peu
de rappel ensuite toutes les petites
pannes vraiment kiki nantes les glaces
qui tombent les petites bricoles les
joints mal fini 7e l'état ça n'existe
pas ces voitures là ne sont pas
commercialisés donc forcément le
consommateur y est très sensible parce
qu'il va pas souvent au garage avec sa
toyota autre stratégie produire au plus
près des clients avec des usines dans 27
pays dont la france et surtout miser sur
des tarifs très compétitifs
la reine elizabeth ii d'angleterre a
adressé ses voeux de noël à ces sujets
avec cette année une innovation de
taille seront diffusées sur internet via
le site youtube ou un canal spécial
royal channel a été créée on y retrouve
tous les moments forts de la vie de la
reine à londres arts le goûter plus
qu'un rendez vous le message télévisé de
noël constitue un rite écouté par tous
les pays du commonweath un monde riche
de vous souhaiter un noël pays
cette allocution et ses archives sont
cette année disponible sur le site
youtube et en un clic on peut aussi
découvrir une jeune reine qui en 1957
présenter ses voeux je vous souhaite
jeunes et vieux où que vous soyez un
noël plein de joie et de paix un très
joyeux noël
à 81 ans elizabeth ii est aujourd'hui le
plus vieux monarque britannique de
l'histoire
cette femme infatigable s'est longtemps
montrée réservée
symbolisant d'abord la tradition il y à
50 ans elle s'étonnait du pouvoir de la
télévision
si certains d'entre vous peuvent me voir
aujourd'hui ville qui est encore un
exemple des changements rapides que nous
constatons dans notre talent il y a le
message d'hier et la réflexion
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas liés on se
rend compte des changements comprendre
ce qui s'est passé il ya cinq ans permet
de mieux comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en ouvrant sur internet
l'album de famille elizabeth ii espère
toucher un public plus jeune elle ne
change pas elle s'adapte et aujourd'hui
elle s'adapte au 21ème siècle la reine
ne découvre pas les nouvelles
technologies car l'an passé déjà elle
avait diffusé ses voeux en podcast c'est
à dire susceptibles d'être téléchargé
sur internet - élégant mais très répandu
aussi sur internet la revente des
cadeaux de noël fait un tabac dès
aujourd'hui des centaines de milliers
d'articles étaient proposés aux enchères
sans état d'âme
reportage romain messi et damian osé
dans cette famille de la région
parisienne tous les cadeaux ouvert ce
matin neutre pas conserver sa ses deux
derniers albums de la série xiii que
j'ai eu cette année est enfin delà de la
bd en fait de la série je les avais déjà
acheter auparavant
donc cela c'est en double v les revendre
cette année des bd revendu en quelques
clics sur internet discrètement et sans
état d'âme
une habitude depuis trois ans pour ce
couple et elle ne se limite pas qu'aux
cadeaux reçus en double ça peut
effectivement aller avant des cadeaux
qu'on aime pas vous pas vexer des gens
qui m'ont hors effets de change pas
forcément mais des des livres bal à papa
c'est d'être politique et de la rue de
lille de politique je les ai revendues
le jour même sans même sans même avoir
essayé de le lire quoi des locaux vides
mais tout se passe sur le site internet
plus d'un million de cadeaux devraient
être mis en vente chez cette entreprise
de commerce en ligne en quelques jours
et la liste est longue les produits qui
sont les plus revendus cette année c'est
le cadre photo numérique qui était
d'ailleurs un des produits les plus
offerts donc c'est assez logique
beaucoup de textile beaucoup de jeux
vidéo des livres est globalement aussi
encore beaucoup de lecteurs mp3 des
cadeaux revendu parfois jusqu'à -40% en
quelque sorte les soldes dès noël
si vous avez acheté du foie gras de la
société montfort sachez que certains au
présent des risques de contamination
microbiologique
il s'agit de foie gras au torchon
authentique 404 130 grammes vous voyez
le numéro du lot qui s'inscrit groupe
coopératif français euralis qui les
fabriquent demande à ses clients de ne
pas consommer ces produits
il y aurait 200 kg de foie gras
concernés à paris de secours catholique
organisé hier soir un réveillant pour
les plus démunis sous le chapiteau du
cirque gruss dans l'oise boulogne un
repas de fête et une soirée de gala
était offert aux familles
edouard baer jean eklou et le compte ils
n'ont pas perdu une miette du réveillon
les 750 personnes invitées des familles
isolées démunis et des toute l'année par
le secours catholique
au menu foie gras dinde et chants de
noël le temps d'un repas naira et sa
fille sans papiers ni logement retrouve
la famille du secours catholique
elles nourrissent des rêves si tu étais
le père noël tu vas portrait quoi ta
maman
l'argent à 39 ans g grande maison
de toutes confessions il partage les
mêmes difficultés rmistes chômeurs ou
sdf violet mineur op éclaté et avoir des
jongleurs et pour les gens leurs
attentes à deux pas d'ici
sous le chapiteau du cirque gruss deux
heures et demie de spectacle pour la
plupart le cirque est une découverte
mon cadeau que je pouvais devenir
vous êtes aussi heureuse que lui ouais
après moi je suis comment nier comme un
enfant hier soir pour ces familles aussi
noël a retrouvé un peu de sa magie
à défaut du cirque les chevaux étaient
aussi à l'honneur en camargue pour la
messe de noël ils ont eu droit d'entrer
dans l'église et son benni une messe pas
comme les autres qui attire croyants et
curieux reportage à saint gilles
veronica guillaume et françoise maso
c'était le privilège des chevaliers de
malte
entré à cheval dans la nuit aujourd'hui
la messe de minuit rassemble cinq à six
fois plus de fidèles qu'une messe de
dimanche ordinaire
l'agneau la nativité
l'histoire se raconte avec simplicité et
chaleur c'est le moment où chacun laisse
de côté cadeaux pouvoir d'achat et crise
de foie mais prenez
le temps du partage de faire pour nous
c'est ce qu'il y ait même si elle est
que trois chats seraient ils viendraient
éviter ce n'est pas la foule qui les
attire c'est leur nom le christ
s'ils sont là c'est que les gars de
leurs traditions qui gardent la foi de
leur baptême et ils viennent entendre la
parole et ça ne peut que leur faire du
bien et ça peut que leur donner envie de
revenir
venus d'ici ou d'ailleurs les brebis
égarées
on fait une pause sur le chemin de
compostelle dans la communion ou par
simple curiosité
l'important c'était cette pause fait
ensemble et ce matin pour les plus
petits c'était la découverte des cadeaux
déposés pendant la nuit par le père noël
un réveil magique pour rod yann et
louise qui ont attendu ce moment toute
une année des veaux garcia et curé
lecomte le 25 décembre au petit matin
c'est toujours magique
diane et louise en nous sauvant bv enfin
il est arrivé en général papa noël
exauce les voeux des enfants
sauf que parfois ils n'apportent pas
tout ce qu'il ya sur la liste dite et
que j'ai connu
l'autre doit être jaloux parce j'avais
pas fais tu lis études et jouer quand
même ce qui est embêtant avec toi père
noël c'est qu'on ne la perçois jamais
est ce que tu as vu le père noël
distribue les jeux jours 7 nuits vous et
vos noms noël merveilleux où les petites
filles se transforme parfois en fait oui
et oui une fête le ch est ça c'est voler
comme le père noël sur son traîneau une
petite chanson l'année sera très longue
en attendant son retour dans les
alpes-maritimes la neige est déjà au
rendez-vous la station de gréolières au
dessus de grâce offre un panorama
exceptionnel
c'est la première fois depuis cinq ans
que l'on peut skier à noël à 20 km de la
mer à vol d'oiseau
reportage à gréolières olivier théron et
virgili à dos le cadeau il est partout
il est géant un noël blanc
de quoi rire et glissé à quelques
kilomètres de la mer ils sont venus pour
la journée en profiter
qu'on s'est dit que gréolières c'était
sympa qu'on pouvait venir facilement et
puis voilà quoi
très belle journée ça y'a pas vous
commande sur les pistes parce que tout
le monde fait en famille moukrim bien
mais il ya quand même de la place pour
les surfeurs de noël la place pour une
première fois en cadeau empoisonné
on y fait renouer lagraulière et on a
voulu si le soft aujourd'hui
mal au genou en souffre mais c'est un
vrai cadeau pour le responsable des
remontées mécaniques l'année dernière à
gréolières il n'y avait pas de neige
un nouvelle grille un noël sans skis
cette année ça démarre beaucoup mieux
puisqu'on a déjà un peu de neige
naturelle on a entre 10 et 15
centimètres il a fait froid puisque ce
matin il faisait encore moins sept
degrés et on est quand même à 21 km du
bord de mer donc c'est exceptionnel quoi
pour nous le début des vacances de noël
c'est l'idéal toutes les pistes ne sont
pas encore ouvertes à gréolières mais le
plaisir est là la glisse ensoleillé fait
rêver même les onglets la neige le
soleil tue ça vraiment des lainages folk
renault ait permis à 10 euros le forfait
gréolières aussi fait des cadeaux ski
plaisir et remonter un vrai blanc noël
et puis il ya aussi le bas de noël qui
fait partie de la tradition pour un
certain nombre d'habitants dans la
manche à tourlaville n'est plus haut des
cieux tente quelques brasses dans une
mer forcément glace et d'autres voulu
payer pour préférer rester sur la plage
et puis à londres foot demers et dans le
serpent pas une légendaire lac de hyde
park quelqu'un elle que londonien
réchauffer ont plongé dans une eau à 3°
il fallait tenir au moins 100 m sans
fouler pour cette traversée hivernale
et pour ceux qui souhaite s'éloigner de
la rumeur du monde les ashrams
d'himalaya attire toujours autant de
touriste rishikesh est la capitale
mondiale de la méditation et du yoga les
beatles y ont même passé quelques temps
pendant leur période peace and love
reportage arnauld miguet et fabrice
launay le long du gange clov sacrés de
l'hindouisme
ces moines en robes orange rappelle aux
visiteurs que nous sommes dans un lieu
sans un lieu où l'on prit parfois en
chansons bienvenue à rishikesh capitale
mondiale de la méditation
il y a de bonnes vibrations ici sur les
causes des saints des rois des empereurs
ont renoncé à tout pour venir à
rishikesh c'est un peu le supermarché la
spiritualité
ici se trouverait la porte du paradis
selon les hindous une porte qui attire
de plus en plus de visiteurs étrangers
en quête de spiritualité
chacun sa méthode pour se ressourcer il
avait ses pêchés dans le fleuve mythique
rishikesh est devenu célèbre en occident
après les séjours dans les années 60 des
beatles
ils sont venus ici dans ce ashram
c'est-à-dire ce lieu retiré où l'on suit
les enseignements d'un mètre d'un gourou
l'ashram aujourd'hui abandonnée est même
devenu un lieu de pèlerinage pour
touristes les beatles ont vécu ici il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent visiter
cet endroit
regardez c'était leur maison et ashram à
rishikesh il n'en manque pas il y en a
même une cinquantaine wolfgang est un
architecte allemand de renom c'est son
quatrième séjour ici dans ce ashram le
plus grand de la ville pour des périodes
de un à deux mois
il troque son 200 m² berlinois pour
cette petite chambre assez spartiate
avec on vient se chercher ici et essayer
de trouver des réponses à toutes sortes
de questions qu'on trouve pas quand on
vit en occident n'est pas trouver la
vérité finale je ne trouverai pas cette
fois ci il la prochaine fois sans doute
mais au moins j'essaye
à rishikesh chacun vient avec l'espoir
de trouver son nirvana son graal
intérieur et chacun y va de son offrande
au camp est au centre du sri lanka des
inondations spectaculaires ont jeté à la
rue
cent cinquante mille personnes selon les
premières estimations
depuis plusieurs jours des pluies
torrentielles ont fait déborder les
rivières on estime à 40 mille le nombre
de familles sans abri beaucoup beaucoup
ont vu se réfugier dans des écoles ou
dans des temples en chine dans la
banlieue de pékin à parcs d'éoliennes
alimentera les installations olympiques
c'est une vitrine pour le gouvernement
qui veut ainsi apporter la preuve qu'il
peut s'intéresser à l'environnement
pascal golomer et sylvain viaut sur
place elles sont sorties de terre le
long de l'autoroute qui mène les camions
de charbon vers les grosses centrales
électriques de pékin
comme un symbole trente trois éoliennes
un petit parc comparé à ce qui se fait
ailleurs dans le pays mais les autorités
chinoises y tiennent beaucoup
elles seront mises en service dans
quelques jours prête pour 2008 elles
aussi d'après les experts toutes les
installations olympiques vont consommer
500 millions de kilowatts pendant les
jeux grâce à ce parc d'éoliennes 20% de
cette électricité sera de l'énergie
propre
c'est ce que pékin s'était engagé à
faire auprès du comité international
olympique liés dont des jeux olympiques
écologie c'est ce que promettent les
chinois à coups de slogans et de
vidéoclips en espérant gommer ainsi leur
image de pollueur mais les éoliennes ne
sont pas là que pour faire joli
depuis deux ans on en installe un peu
partout dans le nord du pays le parc est
déjà deux fois supérieur à celui de la
france
une décision politique les compagnies
d'électricité n'ont pas le choix et nick
1 3% de l'électricité qu'elles
produisent doit être désormais de
l'énergie renouvelable sans compter les
barrages c'est donc choix de l'éolien
soit de la biomasse et cela avant 2010
pour l'espagnol gamesa
comme pour les autres grands fabricants
étrangers c'est une aubaine car cela
garantit des centaines de nouvelles
éoliennes chaque année
mais ils ont tous dû construire leur
usine en chine une obligation imposée
par le gouvernement
jésus halde oit était là pour la pose de
la première pierre il y a deux ans
aujourd'hui ils voient sortir de
l'atelier 15 turbines par semaine et le
site patrie puis de taille l'année
prochaine tout investissement quand même
de risque je vais seulement des risques
contrôlés en tant que dernier sera
épaulé le projet d'année et dix autres
risquent vraiment très contrôlée de nos
libyenne compte dans des tranchées
rendent bien content et je produis le
conclure à ce qu'on connaît bien content
mais alors où la chine s'apprête à
devenir le premier émetteur au monde de
gaz à effet de serre ses efforts en
matière d'énergie éolienne sont
méritoires mais il reste symbolique
surtout quand la consommation
d'électricité elle continue de croître
de façon spectaculaire
paris capitale du marché de l'art pour
la deuxième année consécutive quelques
tableaux exceptionnels ont été vendus à
des cotes jusque là inégalée l'hôtel des
ventes de drouot les maisons d'enchères
artcurial christie's ou sotheby's
annoncent des augmentations sensibles de
leur chiffre d'affaires
christophe féraud et olivier robert un
set sera un grand millésime pour le
marché de l'art c'est sur cette année
les records se suivent et se ressemblent
le 21 décembre pour 11 millions d'euros
voici le miro le plus cher du monde
la bien nommée bluestar une semaine
auparavant de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
jeff koons et son coeur en pendentif de
1 kg 5 est adjugé 14 millions d'euros et
l'autoportrait torture et de francis
bacon 23 milliards d'euros
c'est devenu une compétition à chaque
semaine son record à chaque continent de
nouveaux collectionneurs dans un marché
mondialisé vente aux enchères c'est un
spectacle qui d'abord était locale
nationale et devenu maintenant mon père
donc quand il ya une vente est une
oeuvre importante
tous les collectionneurs du monde sont
là et peuvent mettre des enchères en
même temps en quatre ans le marché de
l'art a connu une progression de près de
100 % passant de 22 milliards d'euros à
1 43 milliard d'euros une forte hausse
due à l'ouverture du marché chinois et
indiens à paris les enchères ont aussi
enflé
christie's encaisse 185 millions d'euros
artcurial 125 sotheby's 119 mais chiffre
impressionnant mais paris ne
représentent plus que 6 % du marché
mondial
il ya 50 ans paris était le principal
marché de l'art de par le monde
depuis il est vrai que d'autres places
new york londres ont émergé et nous ont
relégué à un rôle aujourd'hui en volume
la défense sur le marché de l'art
secondaire 2007 un bon cru d'accord mais
gare aux excès égard aux spéculations
n'oublions pas que c'est cette année qu
un van gogh surestimé n'a pas trouvé
d'acheteur
trois représentations exceptionnelles
encore au casino de paris pour la nuit
des chevaliers nos deux compères sont
donc dans la capitale pour trois heures
de spectacle en deux parties
en première partie une pièce sur un
repas de famille avec la question
cruciale qui va garder mamie à noël
suivie par leurs sketchs les plus
populaires esprit gascon et potache jeux
de mots et s'attire signé les chevaliers
du fiel
il reste trois jours donc à paris jeanne
benzema et m'a dit diawara mallet disons
que les chevaliers du fiel joue ce skate
eu plus vrai que nature
et ça décoiffe sont beaucoup plus crue
au niveau de langage que les hommes
entre eux donc on l'a joué comme ça et
effectivement les femmes qui voit le
spectacle visuel c'est comme ça et vous
au moins vous savez avec oui c'est vrai
depuis que vous êtes divorce et howie
sexuellement je suis bien tranquille
vous êtes en jachère quoi la voilà
la jachère c'est pas pour eux le temps
des fêtes le duo est sur scène pour un
spectacle marathon une pièce suivi d'une
sélection de leurs meilleurs sketches
pourtant juste avant d'entrer sur scène
ils n'ont pas vraiment l'air très c
elle n'aime pas la bûche les confettis à
le jour de noël
bm pourri que vous aurez avec sur scène
il joue de couple un repas de famille
non me dépose toujours une gerbe sur la
tombe de sa fidélité
mon dieu que c'est beau victor hugo non
femme actuelle on arrive encore
s'étonner et surtout se faire rire et
très bon comédien et il fait il est
capable de sans avoir bosser ça mais
deux minutes des animaux d'une manière
totalement surréaliste donc moi je
m'arrange dans les spectacles pour lui
en cases et bernard est refait mois la
biche
j'espère pour une soirée de noël c'est
piquant édition ses actuels à part du
bas mais un morceau de bravoure de trois
heures pour des chevaliers au service du
rire quoi terminer l'année du bon pied
sorcier enfin en salles du film hitman
adaptation cinématographique d'un jeu
vidéo à succès une production au franco
américaine de quoi séduire les amateurs
du genre
emmanuel lambert crâne rasé costume
sombre gros calibre si vous croisez cet
homme c'est que vous allez bientôt
mourir son nom agent 47 sites à fort
tourner son travail agent secret à ça tu
as fait
n'essayez pas de le comparer à james
bond 47 et froid et il ne connaît pas la
galanterie oblige supprime c'est clair
qui d'autre est là
c'était déjà vu comment joue tout à
l'heure tu vas venir avec moi non
mon personnage a été élevé pour être un
tueur
l'histoire montre le tueur dans une
situation qui tourne mal
tout d'un coup il ne sait plus qui
croire
la mission éliminer un politicien russe
une fois la tâche accomplie il se rend
compte qu'il a tué un sosie pris dans
une machination 47 à interpol et le fbi
et les russes à ses trousses les actions
hitman c'est l'adaptation d'une série de
jeux vidéo très célèbre vendu à 5
millions d'exemplaires à travers le
monde les joueurs regretteront l'absence
de scènes calmes au suspense
insoutenable mais pour l'action pas de
problème elle est au rendez vous le
réalisateur et français grand fan de jeu
il était hors de question pour lui de
faire un film d'animation un acteur vous
donne une émotion brute et on n'a pas
besoin d'effets spéciaux juste une
caméra sur un visage en dira beaucoup
plus que n'importe quel effet spécial ou
n'importe quelle image de synthèse qui
vous en mettra plein les yeux
ambiance sombre quelques belles
trouvailles de réalisation hitman vise
un public jeune seul petit défaut
le scénario est trop complexe une chose
est sûre l'agent 47 a les moyens de vous
faire masser tout sauf un joyeux noël et
avant de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle les deux principaux titres
d'abord les vacances présidentielles
avec l'arrivée très attendue cet
après-midi à louxor du nouveau couple le
plus traqué par les paparazzis vous le
voyez le président français nicolas
sarkozy et la chanteuse carla bruni ont
effectué une promenade le long du nil
suivie par une armada de photographes et
de badauds ils se sont aussi affichés
main dans la main à l'entrée du palace
et puis les voeux de noël du pape benoît
16 un appel pour la paix dans le monde
en particulier en irak au liban et en
terre sainte lors de son message urbi et
orbi
enfin je vous rappelle que c'est
aujourd'hui que l'opération une flamme
pour une grippe des tanks aura lieu une
bougie a placé le jour de noël sur le
rebord de votre fenêtre en signe de
solidarité cette bougie elle est là et
ce 25 décembre c'est aussi
l'anniversaire des great qui est
aujourd'hui 46 ans voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci à vous d'avoir suivi
tout de suite la météo présentée par
laurent romejko à 20h53 conte
merveilleux
blanche-neige barbe bleue et cendrillon
avec une distribution exceptionnelle je
ne vous en dis pas plus
vous devriez retrouver quelques visages
familiers très bonne soirée donc sur
france 2 je retrouve demain à 20h bon
choix
l'info continue c'est aussi sur france 2
point fr
tout